bonjour je suis c'est vers une goupille
ou en avant mais les trois enfants je
viens
voilà à mon sens à l'aise un joli
manière erratique au stade j'ai 28 ans
j'habite à pise en italie
bonjour je m'appelle dominique je viens
d'avoir 54 ans et je vous contacte
depuis l'île de saint-martin
manny et ellie five et n'avait jamais le
brésil
je m'appelle chimère j'ai 31 ans et
julien à dakar au sénégal
je m'appelle donc stéphanie vit à miami
aux états unis quant à nicolas voilà
j'ai 30 ans et j'habite à kampot au
cambodge
moi je m'appelle charlotte fait trente
ans les habitats à gaulois une petite
ville sur la côte irlandaise
[Musique]
substitut shops est un homme comme le
gouvernement déclare l'état d'urgence
pour restreindre un peu les libertés
individuelles la fermeture des
restaurants des écoles et des lieux de
culte est aussi un couvre feu est mis en
place entre 20h et 6h du matin dans les
transports urbains public aussi le
manque de passagers devrait être
également deux places assises ce qui
n'était pas le cas avant prester chine
c'est vraiment le seul message qu'ont à
st kaiser à washington
watsco
on doit se déplacer au maximum à deux
kilomètres de chez nous uniquement pour
de l'exercice ou sinon pour faire la
course j'ai fait un compliment au total
au cameroun on à le protéger sur le
théâtre de heurts entre les contenus
aller travail
les marchés sont passés mais les marchés
restent secondaires mois chiffonnette sa
banque le réel de clients et qu on
arrive pendant la journée debout à
partir de 18h tourisme et respect d'un
maître chez nous il n'y a pas encore de
couvre feu il n'y a pas encore de
confinement
pour l'instant le gouvernement a demandé
que tout le monde prenne des mesures que
l'on soit responsable qu'on ne sort pas
trop qu'on se rencontre pas trop depuis
la semaine dernière l'epa
certains bars du moins les barques et
type dit regarde l on confirmait ainsi
que les karaokés tous les restaurants
sont vides les hôtels sont vides
si nous n'avons pas de raison
professionnelle sérieuse ou bien de
raisons médicales de circuler on va vite
bien évidemment à rester à la maison
le gouvernement a été obligé de mettre
des mesures en place mais trop
tardivement et du coup disons à fermer
les plages il ya à peu près une semaine
et les seuls magasins qui restent
ouverts les courses et les restaurants
apporter sinon tout reste de tout le
reste donc fermée il ya personne non non
ça gros ici ça c'est impressionnant
donc ici c'est un hôtel où il ya
normalement du monde de partout
vous voyez ocean drive est complètement
vide poches de son band shopping quand
bon nous on enfilera un whist tous les
matins je me lève ni s commence à
travailler directement
j'essaie de prendre une pause assez
longue vie donc entre 45 minutes et 9 %
de s'ennuyer
[Musique]
je fais me habituel prière petit
déjeuner et regarder les villes puis
soir je vais au boulot ou je suis en
télétravail peut je lis beaucoup plus
qu'avant et même en désarmant je fais du
sport ce que je faisais rarement et je
pratique la méditation ce que je n'ai
jamais été au baron 100 m
[Musique]
enfin je suis en train de préparer mon
conte qui est enseignante en italie et
je n'ai pas arrêté de travailler
l'après-midi la part des leçons sinon vu
que je suis en colocation ça arrive
qu'on passe des choses ensemble et puis
comme par exemple la cuisine s'est
construit aussi un mikado
on a inventé on a dû inventer des choses
pour s'occuper au tout début
est ce qu'en fait il y avait tellement
de monde à aller faire les courses que
finalement les week-ends et le
supermarché qui étaient près de chez
nous fermait certains rayons on n'avait
plus accès par exemple tout ce qui était
loisirs à tout ce qu'était papeterie des
choses comme ça
journée match dépasse ici toujours sur
mon lieu de travail on a dû fermer notre
bas on a dû fermer le restaurant nous
vendons toujours des chambres mais plus
à la nuit en anglais pendant la semaine
ou au mois
de sorte à éviter les allers et venues
des personnes qu'on ne connaîtrait pas
donc soir de limiter les risques au lieu
d'avoir du monde qu'ils mangent et qui
boit et qu'ils profitent des vacances
bain et on n'a personne mais routine du
matin mais ça commence par la photo de
mon petit-fils de métropole mais journée
va écouter dans la sérénité la le fond
musical les bruits du coq décès picpoul
des moments de
relaxation de détente de ballades comme
tous les matins à moins d'un kilomètre
de la maison on n'est pas loin de la
plage de frayeur mais tout cela n'est
pas mieux
personne qui voyage énormément à titre
personnel et aussi pour mon travail j'ai
souvent des voyages à faire mais au
début je comprenais vraiment pas
l'ampleur de ce virus est pourquoi il
prenait des mesures de la sorte je me
suis résigné je me suis dit bon on sait
rien il ya pire dans la vie on se rend
compte à quel point on avait une
richesse
dans nos habitudes de vie dont on se
demandait même plus compte
donc je pense que ça remet un peu les
pendules à l'heure et ça remet un peu
tout le monde au même niveau même si
confinement et véhiculent pas la même
façon en fonction des pays
on passe un peu plus de temps qualitatif
avec nos enfants malgré tout je me
remets à lire que je faisais plus
j'étais voilà tout le temps devant mon
ordinateur
on apprend à lire différemment c'est
vrai pour les moyens vous qu'avant mais
je le prends avec beaucoup de
philosophie en disant que c'est une
situation mondiale qui affecte tout le
monde et tous les secteurs d'activités
qu'on savait tous plus ou moins ce qu'on
allait faire cette année et elle a du
jour au lendemain on sait plus ce qu'on
va faire cette année on sait pas pendant
combien de temps donc ça nous oblige à
voir un nouveau challenge et on en
sortira tous que plus grand enfin
j'espère